wait what Oh too late it's already
starting how is the camera at such a bad
Hasidic angle to me every time I get
screwed
okay Paul rolling am i saying your last
name correctly mercy I wasn't gonna say
it right thank you for being my guest
thank you for you don't even know me
we just met right now but there's a
comedy bond yeah yeah yeah we're kind
enough to say yes and be my guest
yeah and I reached out to you one time
and I think I think I saw something you
didn't I thought it was really funny did
you yeah thank you what was it it was
only been like two funny things that
I've done so you said something it was a
joke about something how your mother was
and I really left and I hate you you
know and I actually said I said some too
like I was like that was really funny I
just want I just want you to know I saw
that I just think it's really funny and
then you were like oh that's nice we had
a nice little chat you didn't [ __ ]
remember yeah yeah like I would have
thought that that would have stuck I do
remember I was playing and part of me is
on this because of that so I thought you
oughta remember knowing that you didn't
[ __ ] remember I would be a halfway to
Scottsdale right now
well you don't remember the night we had
in Albuquerque how dare you how dare you
well no you thought I was Spanish I did
think you were Spanish but you are a
parent I am that's why you're here and
we're gonna talk about how old are your
kids my son is eight and my daughter's
five so yeah okay same with me I'm an
older boy a younger girl six and two oh
okay yeah and eight and do they get
along what's their story with yeah you
know what like she she's very strong
very independent but drives him she
drives him nuts my five-year-old drives
my eight-year-old nuts little bit they
love each other and there's a bond there
yeah but there's definitely like he'll
just be like dad I just she's just
driving me nuts dad I can't and I have
to tell him I'm like Lucas she looks up
to you she wants to be doing the things
that you're doing and she does but like
she goes about it in a way that he gets
he doesn't see yet yeah you know but I
was telling like look man the only
person that's gonna be able to look out
for her as you like you are you know
other than the parents when you guys are
out and
out and they go to the same school you
have to look out for your sister so I'm
trying to put that in there but they go
at it hard you know my six-year-old
loses his [ __ ] mind if the
two-year-old looks at something of his
yeah she's she's looking she's looking
at it yeah she's looking at I go - you
have - this is for the rest of your life
yeah like I don't think they understand
the the length that they're going to be
with this other person yeah
I'm sure when you guys are older you
don't ever talk to each other whatever
that's gonna be up to you but for now
yeah you guys are in it is a marathon
date yeah the funny thing with my kids
is like when he gets mad at her he wants
to prove things she doesn't know so
he'll just go like they'll be fighting
and he'll just be like yeah Sophia so
what's you know you don't even know what
nine plus four is right what's nine plus
four and she'll just be like you're so
mean you are so mean and then I'm and me
and my wife are like Lucas you know she
doesn't know that cuz they didn't learn
it yet you just so what he's like I
barely know you know but whatever he's
[ __ ] with me hard whatever he just
learned right whatever he just learned
he goes home to her yeah like look what
the [ __ ] I know now and I know you don't
know it and and it's and we just you
know he gets really mean to her he
really does and not like he but he loves
her it's weird it's the words they love
yeah my six-year-old thanks me for the
baby all the time thank you so much for
a baby sister thank you so much making
her yeah which I'm like how did you
[ __ ] know we made her because that's
now it's a whole nother level
yeah somehow he figured that out yeah
that's what I'm going through right now
where would the sexual stuff like the
other day we're in a car and she goes
Lucas just did something Lucas just did
something and I was like first of all
Sophia you don't rat your you don't rat
your brother out like you know you don't
do that you don't rat your brother out
but but then I see him act in a certain
way through the rearview I get stitch
and I'm like I'm like weird I'm like
what did you do did you do something and
my son's very like he's really like
empathetic so he knew he [ __ ] up and I
go what did you do and he just starts
blushing and she goes he showed me his
penis and put up two middle fingers
which I inst instantly left because the
two middle fingers [ __ ]
made me like that was I was like wait a
minute cuz I get the private part thing
they're kind of you know I mean it sure
he showed it to her like he's like no no
I think he just he just he pulls it he
pulled it down like just like pulled it
down and then defiantly put up two
middle fingers to her or to the penis no
no no like a penis out and then I think
just like kind of to her but like I just
like this okay so I instantly laugh just
because her the how do you not laugh at
that but then they see me laughing which
isn't good so then I said why did you do
that and he literally goes she goes I
saw it in a rap video that's why he
started watching good or any videos and
I'm like first of all what rapper I
don't know any rapper that's pulling
their dick out doing that now but um
yeah it's things it's things like that
but actually this the story is really
funny because I said I gotta tell your
mother because me and your mother told
you that you got to stop with the
private parts [ __ ] you have to stop with
that we told you multiple times you got
to stop so I said I have to tell him
he's going oh man dad I'm dead aren't I
I'm dead now we're a week away from
going to the shore for a week okay so we
go to the beach for a week and we're a
week away and he's going I'm dead dad
man I'm not gonna be able to go to the
beach am i and we're walking around
Target I have a spot in New York so my
wife comes home from work I just give
her the kids and I gotta run down to
Manhattan yeah
so we're walking around Target and he's
walking around like a man on death row
like he's just head down and he's like
you're really gonna tell her I was like
I can't so we see my wife coming from
the parking lot and he knows it's coming
and I'm just looking at him and I'm like
you know what [ __ ] I can't do it I'm not
ratting my son out I can't I can't do it
I'm not the way he was acting I'm not
doing it yeah so my wife comes in and
he's waiting for it and I just winked at
him I kissed him on the cheek and I said
don't do it again
I love you and I start leaving and
before I even get to the door my
daughter's like Lucas show me his penis
and put up two middle fingers and just
[ __ ] ratted him out and I hope she
said now what's nine plus four
[ __ ]
oh my god I would have loved a yeah tell
her next time yes okay but you know what
he's such a sweetheart he would have
ratted himself out I know he would have
yeah he would have just been like mom I
did this kid I did this thing yeah he's
like my daughter no my daughter will be
my this is how gangster my daughter is
my daughter's [ __ ] gangster man
kidding my daughter said to my wife I
want all the princesses out okay I want
all the Disney Princesses out my
five-year-old daughter who's this
beautiful little adorable girl her room
theme is every villain she got the
[ __ ] princess is out
she's got Ursula this one that one all
across then she's got sketches of all
the villain gowns on her walls she and
she's like the sweetest little and she's
just like no no but now now she's like
maybe one more one princess that was
like a year like so so she's having her
thing but she's having a balance of good
and evil but in love she wouldn't have
ratted herself out my son is the you
know and I'll say this you know since
you have a since you have a a podcast so
we're talking about children now I guess
I'm a serious note somebody said
something to me that bothered me one
time I'm gonna give you gold here even
though you didn't [ __ ] know I was
you're dead to me after with that accent
I can't say that I can say that you're
dead to me it's like ah hilarious
California but that accent makes me feel
like I have a future in a trunk so so
that somebody said to me once and it
bothered me she goes a female comedian
I'm not gonna mention your name but she
just said to me and I'm but she just
said I could tell you you care do you
care more about your son
you care about him want your son and I
bothered me when she said that when she
said it to me she goes I can tell by the
way you're talking you care more about
your son and it bothered me and it hurt
me and I thought about it the rest of
the day and I thought about it at night
because the fact of the matter is I
don't care about my son more I love my
children equally here's what it is when
somebody says you care about a child
more
Moore has a favorite I could tell by
your face that that you you you have a
certain thing here's what it is
mmm-hmm I realized what it is my son
needs me more than my daughter needs me
my son is empathetic my son is sensitive
my daughter is strong and even though
she's younger
my daughter will tell you you hurt my
feelings you hurt my feelings okay
and go [ __ ] yourself I don't like the
weight that you made me feel my son he
internalized it he'll go to his room
he'll think about it my instinct as a
parent was to know my son needs me right
as more than my daughter so that's why
and it made me feel better to know that
I got another great one for you I got
one for you ready for this my wife tells
me today there's a little girl in my
daughter's class named I should I say
the name yeah what the [ __ ] there's a
little girl in my daughter's class named
Makayla my daughter just started getting
on the bus with her brother and in
kindergarten okay and Makayla is being a
problem and my daughter is trying to
make this girl does she's mean and my
daughter's trying to be like I want to
be friends with her because she's acting
like the pack leader and mean but she's
getting upset and sometimes my daughter
is crying so this little kindergarten
girl is making my Sophia upset so
Sophia's gone and she's mean to me and
the other day I had to make my teacher
walk me to lucas's room so my brother
could make me feel better because
Makayla was mean to me so so my y2
started lactating so so so many sweets
so my daughter and my wife have a
conversation and I hear my wife say to
my daughter Sophia people have different
personalities her personality right now
she thinks she's like the leader she's
being rude that's her personality my
wife gets an email from the teacher
today I heard this from my hotel room
here in Phoenix today my wife tells me
yes so you your daughter's teacher got
in touch with me sent an email so what
happened so well Mikayla and her have
been going back and forth and your
daughter's on the receiving end of it
and and what does he say yeah yeah
somebody's a duck Stan's walked away
it's all good and she and she says your
your daughter walked up to Mikayla out
loud and in front of everybody in the
class including the teacher said my mom
says you have a horrible personality
yeah and horrible personality that's
like what a father right now but but now
that parents mother's gonna have to talk
to my wife yes
yeah I would have no problem having that
conversation yeah and and but my wife
was like look I said some things about
personality but I didn't go that I
didn't take it that far
right yeah I said shitty and she kind of
horrible yeah
I said shitty yeah I you know here's the
thing with stuff at school I I come in
with guns blazing I come out with my
dick out and two middle fingers yeah
like an eight year old no but I when
something goes down at school like I
don't [ __ ] around yeah
that is where because you're not there
and as a parent you don't know what
shit's happening and he comes home with
the the six-year-old comes home with
something new every [ __ ] day yeah he
comes home with something that he saw an
older kid do that's the worst
yeah he comes up with a new phrase he
comes home with some like all of a
sudden I don't know where he started
doing peace signs because speaking of
the middle finger yeah in pictures like
he's a Japanese tourist peace sign what
do you what do you need peace for you're
fine that that's the worst you know we
live in a three-bedroom house with a
pool everything is peace
yeah that's you've already achieved it
but he like does it like I don't know
again that some kids saw it but recently
some kids were older kids cuz he's in
the school play so he spends time with
older kids yeah yeah and they were
making origami right I thought that was
cool like a good way to kind of you know
pass the time while they're waiting to
go onstage right and these [ __ ] older
kids made [ __ ] origami which I thought
was actually kind of genius but it was
you know like that old game or it's like
pick a collar red blue yellow green
never that oh great yeah and then the
older kid like Drew [ __ ] hair and
evolved it like he got it like right
like med fresh he had flesh majora and a
menorah
it was biologically accurate but I was
like he's like look mommy pick a color
and it was a vagina
it was I was like oh [ __ ] I'll take the
hemorrhoid I don't know what this is
Larry and then you open up the flap you
know the ones you do like a little
fortune you know yeah you see the like
it goes like three four five okay your
fortune is and and the fortunes were
[ __ ] dirty I mean I very casual you
got to be casual with the kids a thing
if you freak out then they know
something bad happen but I was like oh
this is so beautiful who decorated this
yeah it's like oh it was some you do in
the casualty I don't do I do
everything is casual see my wife and I
fight because my wife tries to do that
and I just tell my son like the
innocence the kids lose come from the
bus and it comes from children with
[ __ ] dumb parents and and because
they're you know so my son will get off
the bus it was so-and-so said this and
I'll be like Lucas someone sells a
[ __ ] idiot they're not that person
that person that person is not any
person person is not raising that kid
right that clears the [ __ ] you're better
you're [ __ ] better than that kid you
know like not like that but right like
kind of just like I don't yeah I don't
I'm not giving him some complex but I'm
just like you know I tell him okay so
where do you draw the line where you say
you're better and then he walks around
is it you know I just leave from that
because that's gonna churn your kid into
that noggin douche going on because know
my when I say better I don't mean you're
better than people I don't know I'm just
like you're better than that dumb [ __ ]
that that person did right you're not
gonna do that right you're not gonna do
that because what I we always tell our
kid is we're always like I'm so proud of
the way you know you can read it's such
a great you know love like you're like
not because he's in first grade I'm like
oh dude you're reading at like second or
third grade level and he looks me he
goes come on mom
yeah fourth yes [ __ ] have we created
yeah the thing is that we tell him he's
so great and then I realize we gotta
take him down a notch yeah and my
husband did that the other day oh my god
he took him down a notch oh yeah he's
this [ __ ] will not blow his nose
here here's the thing when you become a
parent you don't realize you have to
teach well someone had to be a human
like just do basic human [ __ ]
yeah like wipe your ass you gotta teach
someone to do that you can't just say
hey go go in there and wipe your ass you
actually have to like know you do
physically like a diary
in a picture and there's a book with a
bear who's learning how to do it and
there's a cartoon he's got a watch and
Daniel Tiger has to wipe his ass the
other day one of my kids went out of the
bathroom I forgot who it was and I was
like they were like yeah I pooped and I
was like did you wipe and they're like
oh yeah it's not even just one time like
if I told you one time how to do
something yeah you be like oh okay and
then you'll do it cuz you're an adult
and you had life experience these small
people yeah you have to tell them so
many [ __ ] times
yeah and it's ridiculous after a while
you're like are you [ __ ] with me yeah
you know how to wipe your ass so anyways
the point is he wouldn't blow his nose
he has a cold right now and we're like
my husband was just at the end of he's
just I'm done it was like like at
gunpoint almost like blow your [ __ ]
nose laughs he lost his [ __ ] and of
course I come in with like fairy wings
like I'm the Good Witch you don't even
like oh is your nose stuffed up well you
have the power to blow it within you and
I'm always trying to do everything like
you know so gently because I was raised
by you know Russian wolves so I'm trying
to do the opposite of that and I'm like
here's what you do you know find the one
that's stuffed up and my husband just
lost his [ __ ] just like blow you just
like blow your nose and my sixth row
like yeah I don't know how and he goes
you know some people just don't know how
to do stuff like are they in sports or
no he is but it's like not it's sports
adjacent does that make sense so he's
learning how to ice skate right now Oh
play hockey okay so he's he's fall by
usually in the neighborhood of playing
sports or like he'll do like you know
martial arts it's not really sports yeah
but he's starting but you didn't get to
the thing where you saw something either
really awful or [ __ ] incredible
like like where you scored about yeah oh
we're doing basketballs coming up coming
up to my um my son my son plays flag
football right okay start playing flag
football and I had a moment that was one
of the it was it was one of the craziest
things so he played a slot receiver
right yeah the slot receiver and flag
football okay I don't know like yeah
sure just a little yeah he just comes
out of the you know comes out of the
backfield and catches what
it's also a good nickname for me and I
still know you were the [ __ ] you were
Lauren high school actually I wasn't
that's where the joke is yeah I was so
square with the parents your parent you
grew up all right the Wolves the [ __ ]
Russians are the worst so anyway my son
is playing flag football and he's
playing against his undefeated team I'm
not that overly competitive [ __ ] dad
you know so I go I go um listen these
guys haven't lost okay this team you're
playing is undefeated they haven't lost
but you know just just know that this is
a kind of an important game but I wasn't
too much of it
yeah yeah you know so you decide - so my
son he catches this 3 yard pass and he
runs like positive 10 yards and I'm like
oh this is great it's a nice game ok and
then the defenders come up to get him
and I see in his mind that he's going
this is important and he just [ __ ]
turns around and just starts running
negative yardage now so he's plus 12 and
now he just starts running back and the
coaches hand go up and I'm going what
the [ __ ] and then the other dads are
looking at me like that's your that's
your kid like you know when that happens
it's like that's on you yeah and he just
kicks with a dicks out and fingers no
but he runs all the way back in the
backfield now behind the quarterback and
I'm going what the [ __ ] dude what the
[ __ ] and then he turns the corner and he
starts running down positive again gets
out of a like a tackle and just [ __ ]
takes it to the house for a touchdown
and I'm [ __ ] going nuts I'm jumping
up and down all the dads that were
looking at me I'm like [ __ ] you yeah
that's what he did that's what he did
[ __ ]
that's what yeah everyone all the kids
and then he came out and he ran by me
and stuff but then later in the game he
tried to do it again and he got stopped
and it was a mess but you know the coach
is like yeah it's not gonna happen twice
but in that moment what you're saying is
those moments give them it's incredible
what gives them the feeling of it's just
it was just like you know just proud and
I'm sitting there and I was just like
yeah my kid just did that yeah I I'm
looking forward to those he has done
like soccer and he has done some stuff
and everyone tells me I know you got to
get good
but everyone tells me you got to get him
in sports you got to get him like
constantly moving when when how many
hours I'm like you I my husband comes
home and we literally like pass a baton
and I'm in my car driving down to
wherever you know comedy and magic or
Pasadena or wherever I got a spot I when
when do you have time to do so hard yeah
another one you need yeah the [ __ ]
second kid is such a different story it
really is she I think because it sounds
like my my daughter's like yours this
chick is so independent because we
forget about her yeah we'll be like wait
where's the baby
and she's on top of the fridge she once
climbed up to the top of the fridge I
mean she it doesn't matter how old she's
- oh wow she's - but she does everything
by herself yeah and I mean I hope I hope
one day she does say all the princesses
out yeah no she's yeah there's just
villains in my daughter's room I would
like my for a million times it's
everybody comes in and just as like what
the [ __ ] is wrong with that like [ __ ] I
was a guy that's great look I want you
next time you're in LA will you come to
the studio and do yeah I love realsies
yeah yeah thank you gotta go no but time
to go thank you so much it was my
pleasure Paul I'm gonna listen what I'm
gonna do right now I'm gonna bring in
this guy I'm gonna bring enough know I'm
gonna go get my phone I'm gonna look up
that conversation I'm gonna say it on
the podcast the fact the fact that I
wrote the fact that I wrote you
something nice and and you and but
here's the other thing I wrote you
something nice and then you responded
nice okay so there's the nice and then
was last night and then it was like we
just who the [ __ ] so am i am i doing a
negative now negative yards don't worry
I made it around
you made it around thanks for having me
thank you so much thank you
fun times more evil Liriano get your ass
up here Doug Stanhope you're gonna join
are you gonna join Dexter Loreen
valeriano no Haber's e jersey pauper's e
hello I have just staged we walked into
the wrong room cuz there's a pool party
going on somewhere so we all walked in
with no way out and I'm saying to Marie
asked Marie how do I do the right thing
cuz I we have five of us and I
want to walk out in the middle of a
podcast you you could have walked it's
only Heidi people here anyway that was
very nice so anyway I did I'm trying to
whisper I'm [ __ ] hammered of course
so I'm like trying to whisper to all my
friends go out one at a time and then
we'll find this pool party we're
supposed to be in that [ __ ] geeky
pasty Australian guy is the guy that
brought us into this pool party no it's
not a pool party it's an old [ __ ]
Joseph a bank so and I'm asking Marie
what's the right thing to do I was gonna
say oh that's Paul virzi I don't know if
I've met you but I know you from the
[ __ ] don't say that you have it that you
don't know him he's very sensitive about
that well no I don't know if I've met
him I'm 27
it's like being a toll booth attendant
at some point you like yeah I've met
every comic that's ever [ __ ] lived or
I only know him from TV and then I say
hi Amy Schumer I've never met you just
don't want to be a dick and just walk in
you can be a dick right now right now do
you member where we perform together no
give me three hints Las Vegas I'm just
gonna give you the three hints that are
gonna be skeptics remember that [ __ ]
skeptics convention guy yeah I had a
[ __ ] crushing set you mazing and
there was a he was huge it was like over
a thousand people it was over there was
a banquet room where it's a terrible
common terrible but you destroyed we
were dying you were doing the football
bit the end receive what football bit
but a wide receiver sorry the inside
like jokes I had you go all right
what are you open with what's
like like about this show where this
[ __ ] 80 18 people not paying
attention I suppose I'm not even here
you got your guests are you a night out
do you want to join girlfriend you owe
your girls no no we're going to a pool
party or dress is no pool I just came
because I had a great break I'm going
virzi we're going to the [ __ ] pool
party Murray's coming thank you for
coming on for a brief moment
enjoy your pool party see you later
thank you all right Murray valeriano
just what I think Doug Stanhope for
getting out of here in discreetly I
thought that was way to really put that
plan into effect if we kind of file out
of here one by one nobody will notice we
jump on the mic first there's only nine
of us dressed like it's 1974 there's no
way anybody's gonna feel oh hold on let
me commandeer the mic where his pool
party is maybe the Regal Beagle by the
way that's the same outfit he wore when
he and I did that
it's a and I'm not telling tales out of
school cuz he just admitted it Doug is
hammered Yeah right now didn't remember
me on the couch nope until he got up
here he's like Oh Mary didn't remember
it like in East Lake and he said you
know if I could put my eyes together and
focus on you I probably would have a
memory he's like who's up there and I'm
like carrousel Tana [ __ ] I don't know
I'm a tollbooth
things like Paul Bert oh that's versi
Jersey let's sneak out of here um yes
kids right uh can I ask a favor Aaron
since you're walking around Oh Aaron
brung heart you ask a favor
what's that sprung dark-brown card what
did I say fun Garth no I didn't my phone
over there I got to read a quick um I
gotta do a mid role are you having
another [ __ ] the East Coast Italian
on before me oh yeah I forgot your nice
Coast Italian Thank You Aaron I'm
neither East Coast I'm from the ocean
I'm Italian but I'm not East Coast it
I'm not no it's like you're I don't
sound like I'm gonna put you in a body
bag
what are you reading I'm reading the the
mid-roll but I'm also gonna read veer
zis Versys I'm saying everybody's last
names incorrectly
I'm gonna read his a Facebook message to
me so I can remain here no cuz my phone
was Facebook messages to you that you
can read do you do you ever get those
little like bars for your kids for your
kid bar like a bar like a granola bar oh
I'm sure okay so have you seen our X
bars no okay
these are delicious okay and I'm saying
this and they haven't even sent me any I
just get them on my own already oh yeah
they are gonna sponsor the podcast is
even better
Oh Rx those are awesome those are my
favorites I love them no but for
realsies they are so there's three
flavors there's chocolate chip there's
apple cinnamon raisin berry blast I like
it because I throw them in the kids
lunches I throw them in the car they're
always in the car I always have food it
was a gotta have snacks in the car sure
take them anywhere you want breakfast
lunch whatever in the backpack on a hike
if you go to our X bar comm /ki right
use the promo code Kyra at checkout you
get 25% off yes it's a mid-roll Marie
you couldn't have done this
no hey Marie come sit on my podcast as I
do a commercial it's for our X bar it's
important Brody Stephens eight one eight
in the Phoenix
what's a Phoenix areas of code area code
what is it 602 you went to college here
of course he did anyways get your
arsenal party for the kids
thank you for missing it that would be
great
they really are delicious go to our
expert com4 slash kira and use promo
code kira at the checkout you can also
get them at Target oh that's actually
where I buy what if I say carrot the
target if you go to a target line you go
kira 25% off everything Oh everyone just
are leaving the new millennium falcon
bowling awesome alright now it's all
about you okay hi thank you for being my
you are my safety net oh you are my life
preserved
you are my penance you should be saying
this about your husband I can't believe
I drove I drove you drove drove to
Phoenix when today I just got in right
now yeah oh my gosh and I walked in here
like can you do my show yeah why not
I know I just flew in I Drive it they
just why do you drive uh cuz it's five
hours by myself I don't know if you know
this but I've been a single dad but
since July
tell me about and it's not over no it's
going through February
well let me tell you about the last time
so we've spent a week in Atlanta for
what that's where my wife okay so we
don't care so I did me no laughing skull
and I'm going back to you the punchline
in a couple weeks is that why you asked
me about laughing yes exactly yes so we
go we get on the it's just me and Frank
my son flying back and forth um so they
send us and now Atlanta is the [ __ ]
nightmare of an airport it's the worst
Airport I know which star you're gonna
tell I am and told this cuz it's just
haven't you told it too I did oh I want
to hear I told you because we're best
free are you are anything you parenting
or anything have comedy anything we call
each other it's hilarious okay so like
an hour through TSA okay that's awful
the worst is awful my but he's such a
chill kid Nick it's a little
rambunctious okay in an hour and then my
wife had got him these mints cuz he
loves these mints for the plane always
bring he loves the plane because it
means treats and movies yeah for five
hours yeah so he loves it so he's just
shoveling these mints Fistful and so
he's happy he's just make it through TSA
get on the plane back in the plane all
the way to the back you know we sit down
I set him up I got his ear plugs in I
put on a movie I decide I'm gonna take a
nap
you know I can get at least an hour
while ago the movies we take off it's
one of the most turbulent flights I've
ever been on ever I mean it was like you
know the one where you think oh this one
this one might be it you're not really
convinced but you're like this could be
flight once where the flight attendant
screamed oh that's
good landing in in Utah what's the place
where Sundance's Park City okay Lander
Park City yeah okay landing there oh no
no I'm sorry was asked me we were
landing a NASA yeah oh yeah makes more
sense yeah
and because between the mountains yeah
and it was so turbulent the flight
attendant went oh how was it I was like
well if you know what it was a good run
yeah all right so turbulent I was flat
hold on this is a different story I was
flying out of Seattle during a storm and
the flight the the people on the thing
said we're gonna try to get to Los
Angeles but we might have to be diverted
to San Jose we're telling you this
because if we get to if we have to go to
San Jose you are responsible for your
flight to Los Angeles wait if there's a
storm where was the storm in San
Francisco I guess so oh okay there so
we're gonna get diverted Europe but
we're gonna try which was the great
thing so I'm on the plane with like two
sixteen-year-old girls from Venezuela in
the row next to me and it is up and down
and cone all over us and I'm fine this
is when I was really scared of flying
I'm [ __ ] a brick right and this
little like Latino girls like okay and
I'm like yeah yes dear we're gonna be
fine and I held her hand and I looked
out the window it was like that was the
worst player in this is the second-worst
yeah very real it's off the plane boof
boof I fall asleep getting kind of
rocked to sleep and I feel my son kind
of just brushed my arm and I don't think
about you know I just think he's
stretching or whatever and then a few
minutes later brushed my arm again blow
it off I didn't know he's active you
know he's enjoying it he's getting more
mints he's doing everything brushes my
arm a third time it was oh boy and I
looked down and he looks at me and he
points down and has barf all over the
place just full-on just down his pants
I didn't I had headphones on and it's
noisy in an airline in an airplane
and I'm a terrible father I was
listening to sergeant pepper's you know
my kid would have screamed that's what
I'm saying your kid is pretty chill
right now just glared at me glared at me
and pointed down and it was down his
front of his shirt all over his pants on
the seat and the front seat in front of
them in the pocket oh my god on the
floor mints did he eat that's the great
thing is it didn't smell it smelled
minty didn't smell like puke
it smelled like mints so nobody like no
and I've thought about this my whole
life like oh my god I'm gonna be so
mortified if that ever happened to me
I'd be so apologetic to all the parents
and all that but I was like [ __ ] him
this is my kid he's sick I gotta take
care of him ya know change of clothes ya
learn that one such you that is such a
non-union move I know I fine you know he
grew out of the you know peeing and
crapping himself on the plane so I
didn't you know we we fly all the time
yeah him and I and we've never had that
problem so it was so not the
stewardesses were really nice I took
them 20 bucks and they cleaned it off
they did they cleaned up the seats I
mean I rinsed out his Clyde to sacrifice
the shirt there was no saving that but
so I threw that in the trash and I
rinsed out his pants and like they hung
dry them in the back for me and then
they put gave him two blankets and made
a little toga and then set him up and he
was probably more comfortable than any
of us he was rushing a fraternity in the
80s so man that was you 15 minutes into
a five-hour flight oh my god and what
are the people around you saying nobody
really said he the woman because I was
on the aisle I get the aisle with him
and then he gets the middle and the
woman thank God turned out to be a
mother a grandmother and a nurse so she
had seen it all so she didn't care oh my
god and so now you have learned though
right oh absolutely change of clothes
the whole time I've seen if I get a
picture of you and them in the toga
[Laughter]
but he was fine after that and then I
gave him a granola bar in Rx get 25% off
go to a sex bar at the Bing stewardess
button just said Kira Kira
I like the oxygen mask our X bar bars
just fell out of this town you they come
in handy but now when you travel mm-hmm
could you travel a lot yes you are gonna
bring clothes absolutely now I'm totally
gonna bring clothes for sure you have to
absolutely yeah I didn't mean I didn't
even register it and I'm an over-packer
that's the weird thing
yeah me too like I probably brought five
outfits for this weekend I'm doing three
shows I brought way too many clothes I'm
leaving tomorrow morning flown in this
sets slept in you know a toga absolutely
United Airlines toga are you doing The
Improv tonight yes that's gonna be
that's a heavy hitter show yeah yeah
yeah 7:30 yeah it's me you okay that's
all I need that's right there joke never
gets old and when you say have your
hitter it's because you're abusive yeah
yeah yeah I slap the [ __ ] out of my kid
for puking on the plane did you oh yeah
how's he gonna learn
come on one minute at a time buddy one
minute at a time aye aye
we're going to Hawaii for the first time
my kid we're going to Maui my kid has
never been on a flight longer than an
hour oh yeah the older one the baby has
but she was she's kind of Florida with
me and in other places but he's only
been a snack just go back and forth a
bunch of times so we'll see yeah taking
two kids and your kids at Brad a little
bit he's not you know here's the thing
with my kid he is so [ __ ] amazing hmm
like I I'm gonna show you a video later
I can talk to about almost anything
right sure like really almost anything
it doesn't matter I'll bring up the most
random weirdest things period he
right that's right it's natural and he
is on board and wants to talk about
anything okay but it's the things that
are like kid related you know so like
hey you're not allowed to you know play
right now because we got to eat dinner
like it's that it's that magnified so
it's like when he's cool he's hella cool
right when it's something that he
doesn't want to do or what or he asked
for thing I say no he loses his mind but
it's it's like the full spectrum
spectrum spectrum pendulums whatever him
specula right up here oh I know so I was
I was driving with him right and the
baby wasn't in the car so I like to do
like really just cool
mommy Braden stuff with a baby's on the
car we crank the music we crank the
music we talk about fun stuff okay so
here I don't know if I'll just put it on
the microphone I talk I try to convince
him to be Ralph Malph for Halloween okay
I try to convince him to be Ralph Malph
let's see if it works okay
[Music]
yeah so you could have it could be a
redhead
what if he has four arms I have my
blinker on there's a point to this
[Music]
but he's the fonts and he could do stuff
like he could like paper towel dispenser
[Music]
totally happen why was that wrong
because he doesn't hit this towel
dispenser in a door opens he hits the
jukebox or the low yeah okay
the earlier ones yes but later on in
different later seasons after they
jumped the shark yes he would hit a
paper towel dispenser in like a bathroom
door the stall door would open Aaron
Aaron's too young
yeah no I don't is that Mike back there
yeah he wouldn't anything and anything
would happen god dammit alright
Mariano fine he would hit a payphone and
times would come out and he'd hit a girl
and all the girls that come up all right
see I have all right so it's Halloween
okay Gord this okay and part of Frank's
that's my son homework was to write a
Halloween joke okay and so here's this
Halloween joke I recorded it and sent it
to his mom because she's not with us no
she's no longer with us
[Laughter]
the late
Mary's ovaries she's supposed to be here
an hour ago that's me that's not Frank
he's not 47 years old only because it
ties into yours okay I'm all yours
to do a Halloween choker school
experience hey you ever heard destroying
the ghost cross the road well here it is
one of the ghost cross the ghost crossed
the road and you know why what cuz we
needed to go potty and across the street
was the only toilet in town
that's half Apple fog doesn't fall too
far from the tree I'm opening with that
tonight hey guys want to hear a joke
about things I couldn't punch that up
for him a little why come on I don't put
the pressure on him you got it I told my
kid I tell him worst comes to worst drop
your pants boom
where's the potty if you do that you can
work at The Comedy Store what else was
happening in your life what are you
doing like every night you gotta make
dinner and do the bath and put him to
bed every single [ __ ] night yeah you
have a sitter or if I'm working yeah if
I have a spot every sitter come and then
I gotta get up in the morning get him
breakfast and get him and take him to
school and then on the weekends you guys
have to fill all that time to on the
weekends mom comes home and yeah it's
like Audi gone Wow annex and what movies
she working on kids can you say I don't
know okay you can always google it
that's what I say anybody ever asks cuz
no one's going to do that that's fine
who has the time for that [ __ ] no
but you know what's great about taking
over school in the morning is we're two
blocks away so I walk him to school
every morning
that's gorgeous fantastic yeah and then
I pick him up i skateboard I have a
longboard skateboard and I carry his
bicycle in my hands right helmet and I
skate over to pick him up and then he
gets on his bike and he's guys oh that's
so we come back and there's been a
couple times when I've been skating and
like one of the mobs like oh cool dad
yes yeah she's late I mean not late
she's about regular with its periods
again Oh like second third day of school
I'm skating to pick him up I've got my
helmet on I've got his bicycle his
helmet phone keys wallet it's just in my
pockets you know
skating over pick him up we come to an
intersection and there's not like a
drainage groove in the intersection and
I'm thinking all right yeah I've I've
navigated this before I'll just you know
you lift your weight up you kind of jump
up when you go over a dip that way the
wheels go over it and then you come down
right and I judged it wrong and I went
up and I came down the back wheels
locked skateboard stopped I went flying
into the intersection just helmet
bicycle keys Walt like a yard sale in
the middle in the middle of it they
ripped these pants those are all patched
up bleep bloody need cut up my hands I
get up I turn around my neighbor is in
the car in the intersection with her ten
year old girl and five of her best
friends just like three days later I go
to school did I drop Frank off I welcome
I drop him off I walk out I run into the
little girl and her friends well you're
never gonna have sex with them then take
off leave it to me to miss walking one
of the staff members yeah well he knows
what he did that's a her know she is
alive she comes home every weekend who
do you think that is father's getting
ghost texted that's an MTV show right
Aaron ghost I was texting my kid
speaking of ghosts is so much talk and
then when it really comes down to it
he's like I want to hear a really sad
story no sure a really scary story and
I'm like okay so I found like a scary
podcast for kids like a scary ghost
story cuz they're all over the place now
and he's listening to it and his whole
face is just like so scrunched up the
whole time listening I was like hey are
you are you enjoying this is like yes
but he's freaked out out of his
mind and he won't say he's scared and
then it's over and he was like that was
that was very scary
I checked in with you I checked in like
do you sure you want to continue with
this and you don't he said to me he goes
bad parenting but I mean it's like you
can't win with these kids they want to
do like scary stuff it's all around and
then he's like I'm gonna have nightmares
now it's like dude my kids way he's been
acting scared a lot lately and I don't
know why like he doesn't want to go into
the bathroom by himself you know he
likes I let him watch Scooby Doo while I
get the bath ready and he wants me to
sit with him to watch Scooby Doo cuz it
can get scary yeah why do you let him
watch us could we do then cuz he likes
it he wants to yeah seems like it's
tonight a scooby-doo night right alright
I was just gonna say drugs your wife
needs to come just McDonald do you guys
you guys have to do it on the weekends
then like you have to do it every
weekend
what shopping food shopping bills
oh yeah Lana you got to do it on the
weekends right no what I'm saying is
like it makes it like the pressures on
right like she's coming home for the
weekend you're like we have 48 hours
sure you try it wait are you saying you
guys don't know I'm saying that's what
we do it yes yes that's pressure is what
I'm saying no not for me okay I've been
around the block all right yeah well and
sometimes you fall around the block oh
shut it
all right where your spine you guys do
sex well that's the thing it's like it's
can you know it's whenever we're two
kids it's whenever whenever we can oh so
here's XT never next to never no but
here's a fun little thing we figured out
we could do my husband is working pretty
close to home right now it's not for
very long cuz it's gonna go back to
Beverly Hills but right now it's pretty
close
when the kids are at school during the
day what I know that's a what are you
would you grow up in a church what is
that like it's a called a nooner man
I understand but we've never really been
able to do that because it doesn't
matter that it's you know the kids are
at school he's always been so far from
home right but now for a little short
while he's close by so it's nice so what
do you do quick it's fast I mean you get
all ready for him no you know what Shh
our God deodorize I would do anything
different than normal yeah what'd you
get
he saw my passport picture a refugee uh
where are your shows tonight because
we're gonna wrap up sake The Improv I
think I'm with you you're with me
I think so okay you in 2 or 1 or 3 I
don't know whatever they want to do
whatever they want to give me then
you're going back tomorrow I'm leaving
tomorrow yeah because I am producing a
game show I know you know
oh no but tomorrow there is I'm going
back because I have a corporate all
right yes in Ojai oh I gotta get back my
dad's in town I love your dad tell me I
said hi
well I know you guys love each other he
loves you and Angeles iruka's who
doesn't two comics he asks about all the
time thank God Angela Angela circus is
so nice he's Greek and I married a Greek
yeah my dad thinks you're Greek ok it's
fine how are those two great guys
because you guys the two Greek guys I
was so glad I'm Angelo tsarouchas I met
and he gave me his DVD which is in Greek
or something like that so I gave it to
my father-in-law so now my father-in-law
can stop asking me about Zach
Galifianakis finally the only other
Greek in comedy now I can are there any
others I don't think so there's some
couple Africa sir
oh yeah Stocki kind of malice mister
wait what's his name the stereo a stereo
stereo spoke he knows something like
that he looks a lot like a young Jerry
Garcia Google Image both of them image
okay and then there's I think there's a
dino Stan innopolis but he's more of a
writer Oh Dena yeah yeah
yeah Oh stocky economist yeah [ __ ] those
great names yeah I know
and Aaron got pissed at me for [ __ ]
up his name yeah like I [ __ ] care
Aaron Kasden oculus Aaron wait dude
Aaron has so many silent H's in his name
it's ridiculous
there's two and Aaron alone what now did
they cut down your name Alice Island at
Ellis Island mmm no we flew here oh you
know I'm sorry to avoid the escapees we
didn't we didn't have it was a non-stop
oh yeah we know they didn't cut why
would we do that
music zippedy did that to my wife's dad
but he's older true yeah oh my momma's
parents came through Ellis Island and
they didn't they didn't fix that last
name at all what was their what's their
last name buzzed off go be ZD 8 WK do
you just call me right
my family must have landed close to
lunchtime wait where are you where's she
from
Paulin buzzed Africa that sounds like a
word and it's a fucked-up word do you
know what what's that my mother yeah
where are you from
no were you from the Ukraine oh right
yeah but that sounds like it's like
that's like a word in Polish boost
Africa yeah no that's that means
something yeah
that means like you know some sort of
like criminal or something they cut a
Mary's Mary's last name is was like zof
innopolis or something like that that's
me that oh you know you guess what guess
what I just found out I've been
pronouncing my wife's name wrong for 10
years I don't feel bad now saying
Aaron's wrong like what she shortened it
like when I cuz I follow her on Facebook
don't I know she's not Facebook or I
follow I see something thought freeze
right yeah but I was saying so freeze
and I've known her for 15 years and then
at like I think I was at the Academy
Awards or something I feel like your
heart's not in this marriage
[Laughter]
now you sound like my father-in-law
asked me about Andrew Seleucus I feel
like you just not really like your
half-asses who would have said who
wouldn't you have set like on your
second date like would have been that's
actually saw freeze but instead I find
out I think we're at the Academy Awards
and somebody reads off her name and I go
oh yeah I go I get that all the time
everybody else is my name wrong she does
what do you mean we go they said saw
freeze I've known you for 15 years we
have a child together we have a mortgage
you're telling me now I've been
pronouncing your name wrong I feel like
that someone's bit like there's a comic
that's like well I didn't think I would
know you for that long so I never
corrected you like I didn't think we
would go out again like there's
someone's bit but no maybe it's mine and
you're ruining it right all right Murray
it's always a joy yeah my name is Marty
so it's no big deal no she didn't um
let's go to the pool party all right
yeah I think there's food up there is
there yeah Aaron and big I'm gonna bring
you something Aaron is she's here what
would you like I don't know whatever
whoever's there that's the right answer
mm-hmm I'll be back here at the what do
we call this Aaron what are you doing
here I can hop up podcast do you have it
to you by Bud Light and Tito's vodka
Tito's I'll be here tomorrow night at
nine o'clock doing your pot can my
podcast who's your guest I don't have
one yet okay I got possibilities yeah I
was around yeah loosey-goosey lots of
folks there's 9,000 comics here maybe
Doug Stanhope will swing by maybe have
some more and not remember anything that
happened just now that was fun I've
always wanted three guests at one time
right right it's my first foursome no
it's not no all right let's go let's go
enjoy it thank you
Kara's listeners bye bye